[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen ihnen ein an
diesem ostersonntag wo die cs auch
wieder mit dabei für den sport hallo
schön und wir haben unter anderem diese
themen für sich
verschanzt im stahlwerk ukrainische
soldaten geben mario voll licht auf
russland droht ihnen mit dem tod
minister botschaft in rom papst
franziskus fordert frieden in der
ukraine und spendet den segen urbi et
orbi wieder vor tausenden gläubigen
und ab in die ferien in deutschland
lockt die sonne nach draußen an der
ostsee freut man sich auf viele
touristen
der krieg nimmt keine rücksicht auf
ostern in mario pohl ist schlimmste zu
befürchten
die stadt ist mittlerweile offenbar fast
vollständig unter russischer kontrolle
die verbliebenen ukrainischen soldaten
weigern sich aufzugeben ein ultimatum
der russen ließen sie verstreichen jetzt
droht moskau sie bei gegenwehr zu
vernichten volker tucek
das off stalberg ist ein riesiges thema
direkt am meer elf quadratkilometer groß
ein drittel des ukrainischen staates
wurde hier bis zum krieg hergestellt
jetzt haben sich hier soldaten der
ukrainischen armee verschanzt zum teil
in einem tunnelsystem von 2.500 kämpfern
spricht das russische
verteidigungsministerium
darunter angeblich viele soldaten aus
dem ausland
nach angaben von gefangenen ukrainischen
soldaten sind auch 400 söldner aus dem
ausland dabei viele aus europäischen
staaten aber auch aus kanada
am mittag verstreicht die frist die
moskau den ukrainischen soldaten in
mario pohl gesetzt hat sie wollen sich
nicht ergeben präsident zielinski hat
den kreml gewarnt die soldaten zu töten
ich glaube die russen machen einen
großen fehler wenn sie unsere leute
mario porten wir dass das ende für jedes
format von verhandlungen bedeuten
das russische staatsfernsehen zeigte am
nachmittag bilder die aus mario pohl
sein sollen angeblich seien die
ukrainischen soldaten im stahlwerk
besiegt zahlreiche waffen sichergestellt
beweise für diese behauptung gibt es
aber nicht
der russische beschuss im nordosten des
landes geht weiter vor allem in hf dort
wurden mindestens acht menschen getötet
dutzende verletzt
die behörden in der zweitgrößten stadt
der ukraine sprechen von mehr als 20
angriffe mit raketen und artillerie an
einem tag
dominik löschmeister im care schauen wir
noch mal auf mario pohl warum ist der
widerstand der soldaten in dieser stadt
so wichtig für die ukraine
ist für die ukraine eine wichtige stadt
sind sie ist aktuell die einzige stadt
damals oft mehr im moment noch von der
ukraine kontrolliert wird der rest in
diesem gebiet wird von den russen
besetzt gehalten deswegen will die
ukraine hier kämpfen und es geht auch
darum truppen zu binden vor allen dingen
auch truppen der russen denn die
russische armee hat ja angekündigt in
den nächsten tagen eine offensive zu
starten in der ost ukraine
und es geht darum vor allen dingen für
die ukraine zeit zu gewinnen das heißt
man will russische kräfte weiter binden
um waffen aus europa zu bekommen und
truppen auch in das gebiet in die
ostukraine zu bringen um diesem angriff
der jetzt auch in den nächsten tagen
droht auch irgendwie stand zu halten und
präsident selensky sagte auch heute im
dom bass entscheide sich auch das
schicksal der ukraine dankeschön für
diese einschätzung live aus kiew dominik
löschmeister
seit beginn des krieges ist mario pohl
im visier der russen seit anfang märz
haben sie die hafenstadt mit einst mehr
als 400.000 einwohnern eingekesselt die
lage muss katastrophal sein newton
leinhos über eine stadt die zum symbol
in diesem krieg geworden ist
mario ball ist für die meisten ukraine
lange schon eine heldenstadt die
menschen hier sprechen überwiegend
russisch gleichwohl haben sie russische
angriffe immer wieder erfolgreich
abgewehrt diese friedlichen bilder
entstanden im februar kurz bevor die
hölle über mario pohl hereinbrach
wochenlanger raketenbeschuss und
flächendeckende zerstörung haben den
widerstand bis zur stunde nicht brechen
können für moskau hat mario pohl große
strategische bedeutung als
landverbindung von donetsk und lugansk
auf die annektierte krim ziel des
russischen militärs ist es die wichtige
fernstraße m14 komplett unter kontrolle
zu bringen um die krim sicher mit den
separatisten gebieten zu verbinden schon
2014 waren versuche russischer
separatisten gescheitert mario ball zu
erobern auch weil die zivilbevölkerung
sich den angreifern entschlossen
entgegen stellte seither so die
ukrainische lesart hat moskau mit den
menschen in mario pohl eine rechnung
offen von anfang an bekamen sie die
volle wucht des russischen angriffs zu
spüren bei der zerstörung einer
geburtsklinik der attacke auf hunderte
flüchtlinge in einem theater schließlich
konnten selbst massengräber die vielen
toten kaum erfassen
noch leben vermutlich mehr als 100.000
menschen in mario pohl in weiten teilen
eine geisterstadt tiefe ihren widerstand
einen hohen preis bezahlt
die eu arbeitet daran bei den nächsten
sanktionen gegen russland auch öl
einzubeziehen das sagte
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen der
bild am sonntag
es brauche aber kluge mechanismen damit
russland auf anderen märkten nicht noch
höhere preise bekommen derzeit zahlen
eu-staaten täglich etwa 450 millionen
euro an russland für öllieferungen
wir dürfen uns nicht an den krieg in der
ukraine gewöhnen so der appell von papst
franziskus in seiner osterbotschaft der
friede sei eine pflicht und die
vorrangige verantwortung aller erstmals
feierte der papst die ostermesse wieder
mit tausenden gläubigen auf dem
petersplatz aus rom andreas postel
nach zweijähriger unterbrechung durch
die pandemie haben sich beide pilger und
pontifex genau danach gesehnt die
gemeinsame ostermesse auf dem
petersplatz in rom doch die große freude
am höchsten fest der christenheit ist
überschattet vom blutvergießen in der
ukraine und dem leid so vieler menschen
in der welt
ich wünsche mir frieden das in diesen
tagen der krieg endet und auch das
corvette endet weil wir alle erschöpft
sind es braucht in der welt mehr
menschlichkeit und güte
in seiner osterbotschaft ergreift papst
franziskus mit erneut deutlichen worten
partei spricht von der leidgeprüften
ukraine vom grausamen und sinnlosen
krieg in den die ukraine hineingezogen
wurde
hat auf die muskeln spielen zu lassen
während die menschen leiden
bitte
bitte gewöhnen wir uns nicht an den
krieg setzen wir uns alle dafür ein von
unseren balkonen und auf den straßen mit
lauter stimme den frieden zu verlangen
den frieden
traditionell erteilt der 85 jährige
pontifex zum abschluss den segen urbi et
orbi der stadt rom und dem erdkreis
höhepunkt der feierlichkeiten in rom mit
der osterbotschaft dass angst schmerz
und tod nicht das letzte wort haben
das leid in der ukraine bestimmte auch
die oster botschaften der kirchen in
deutschland der vorsitzende der
katholischen bischofskonferenz bätzing
sagte man dürfe die hoffnung auf frieden
nicht aufgeben
der evangelische landesbischof in bayern
bedford strohm erinnerte an die
verzweifelten menschen in der ukraine
aber auch an die russischen soldaten
mitte die um ihre söhne trauern
die preise steigen und steigen grund
genug für die gewerkschaften in den
kommenden tarifrunden auf deutliche
lohnerhöhungen zu pochen insbesondere
gering und normalverdienende seien
belastet sagte der dgb vorsitzende
rainer hoffmann dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland deshalb bleibe der
inflationsausgleich ein hauptziel trotz
der schweren krise der zeit
seit langem schon will nordkorea seine
kapazitäten für einen atomschlag starten
jetzt hat es laut staatsmedien eine
neuartige lenkwaffe getestet die mit
taktischen atomsprengköpfen bestückt
werden kann unabhängig überprüfbar ist
das nicht gerade erst hat machthaber kim
jong un eine parade zu ehren seines
großvaters des staatsgründers kim il
sung abgenommen
ab september könnte es einen speziellen
corona impfstoff für die omikron
variante geben das kündigte
gesundheitsminister lauterbach in der
bild am sonntag an er rechnet zum herbst
auch wieder mit steigenden fallzahlen
aktuell gehen sie zurück laut robert
koch institut ist die sieben tage
incidents auf 834 3 gesunken an den
feiertagen wird allerdings weniger
getestet und weniger gemeldet
osterurlaub der blieb in den letzten
beiden jahren coruna bedingt weitgehend
auf der strecke jetzt drängt es viele
raus in die berge oder an die küste zum
beispiel nach mecklenburg vorpommern
erst vor drei tagen entfiel dort in
vielen bereichen die testpflicht für
ungeimpfte jetzt wächst die hoffnung
dass 2022 endlich wieder ein gutes
urlaubsjahr wird eine stadt fällt
schnell noch dekorieren in ihrem hotel
restaurant in kühlungsborn die
stellvertretende direktorin christine
bands packt überall mit an im hotel gilt
weiter 3g im restaurant nicht mehr das
erleichtert ihr den saisonauftakt
wir arbeiten weiter nach 3g verordnung
sind es aber inzwischen auch geübt und
aber für die gastronomie für die
restaurants und für alles ist das ganz
wichtig dass da jetzt auch wieder
lockerungen in kraft treten ihr hotel in
erster reihe am strand ist so gut wie
ausgebucht insgesamt werden rund 300.000
gäste während der osterferien in mv
erwartet urlaub hier wird allerdings
teurer bis zu 15 prozent gestiegene
kosten für energie und lebensmittel
schlagen durch die urlauber schrecke das
aber nicht ab die gäste müssen das auf
irgendeiner weise auch akzeptieren dass
halt die preise dadurch müssen steigen
ist leider so aber jeder will wissen
über leben halten wenn ich das die
leistung haben möchte die ich die ich
hier bekomme dann muss ich eben auch mit
diesen preisen leben ja vielleicht mal
eine kugel eis weniger als sonst aber
ansonsten lassen wir uns davon
eigentlich die groß beeindrucken ja
gegen korona machen die deutschen
weiterhin lieber urlaub im eigenen land
heißt das vom tourismusverband
wir wollen jetzt eine stabile
kontinuierliche saison fahren sind
motiviert gucken nach vorne und wollen
mit den rest beschränkungen die es immer
noch gibt denn die pandemie ist endlich
vorbei auch lieben
die branche rechnet in diesem jahr mit
etwa 10 millionen gästen mv das käme den
rekordjahren schon sehr nahe
fußball das hat auch nicht jeder menge
genau die fußballerinnen des vfl
wolfsburg haben ihre triple chance
gewahrt und sind ins dfb pokalfinale
eingezogen
die mannschaft gewann bei meister bayern
münchen mit 3 zu 1 damit hat der vfl am
28 die chance auf den neunten titel
gewinnen
gewohntes bild im pokal die wolfsburger
seriensiegerin jubeln die bayern wie
schon in den vorjahren gegen den vfl
heraus das halbfinale vor 2300
zuschauern zunächst mit schlechten
nachrichten für wolfsburg
nationalspielerin lena oberdorf muss
nach einer viertelstunde verletzt vom
platz wenig später die vfl-führung aus
der drehung chirurg drangphase der bayer
nach der pause damiano wird nur durch
foul zu stoppen die serben verwandelt
den elfmeter selbst doch roth bringt
wolfsburg nach fehler von kumagai wie
der in führung die entscheidung
sehenswert tabea waßmuth im finale
trifft wolfsburg auf leverkusen oder
potsdam am kommenden freitag geht es
erst mal in der champions league nach
barcelona
und im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga haben die bayern in bielefeld
mit 3 zu 0 gewonnen und damit ihren neun
punkte vorsprung in der tabelle auf
dortmund wieder hergestellt bielefeld
liegt auf dem vorletzten tabellenplatz
deutschlands handballer haben sich für
die weltmeisterschaft im kommenden jahr
in polen und schweden qualifiziert nach
dem 34 26 im hinspiel gegen die färinger
siegte das team gestern abend in torsten
mit 33 zu 27
durch den erfolg im ko-duell gegen den
krassen außenseiter qualifizierte sich
die dhb auswahl zum dreizehnten mal
nacheinander für eine wm
der niederländische radprofi die lahn
von baden hat den schwierigen ein tages
klassiker paris roubaix gewonnen der 29
jährige setzte sich nach
257,2 kilometern davon viele abschnitte
auf den berüchtigten kopfsteinpflaster
souverän nach einer solofahrt im finale
durch bester deutscher john degenkolb
auf platz 18
so kann man seine user sonntag
verbringen es war richtig heiß da das
wetter beschert weiter freude am
ostermontag ziehen über die osthälfte
einige wolken dabei werden zehn bis 16
grad erreicht in der westhälfte scheint
meist die sonne und die temperatur
steigt auf 16 bis 20 grad und die
kommenden tage bringen neben sonne
überall wolken am dienstag fällt im
südosten auch etwas regen marietta
slomka begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute-journal hier übernimmt morgen
ja na park ist das gesamte team der 19
uhr wünscht ihnen vor ostern und alles
gute auf wiedersehen
[Musik]